bienvenue à la mdd couronneries ghisi
vous avez l'accueil où vous attendent et
lorsque vous avez plein rendez vous
j'appelle mélanie j'ai 21 ans et je suis
dans toutes lés mds de poitiers pour
aider les usagers sur les démarches
administratives en moi c'est elodie j'ai
20 ans j'ai arrêté c'est celle que nuit
sociale familiale et cette année je suis
enfin suivi le département pour aider
les troisièmes à trouver un stage est
enfin devenue une élève qui est en
recherche de stage que j'ai une tête des
chaînes principales et chantal berger du
ca
motivation j'ai découvert sa visite par
le biais d'une amie qui avait des études
commençait un service et son école et du
coup ça m'a poussé à regarder l'émission
qui avait sur poitiers et a trouvé cette
mission qui met alors j'aimerais
poursuivre dans la voie de
l'administration est sûrement passer les
concours de préparation la catégorie b
pour devenir secrétaire administrative
j'aimerais faire une licence
professionnelle interventions sociales
pour critère pour voir écouter un son à
l'insertion professionnelle vous
conseiller en économie sociale fait
mieux que sa veuve est de
professionnaliser d'entrer dans le monde
du travail mais tout en gardant du dans
la côte et ça me permet de travailler de
projets d'avenir ça sert également de
console habilité dans la faune plus sur
différents métiers
[Musique]